in today we are going to work on the
endgame but before a couple of exercises
for you to warm up so in this position
that you see on the screen why to start
and you have to find the winning
variation first of all you will need to
write down the main move and then two
variations after this move so I will
give you the hint you see the rook on
the C file you see the Queen and the
night you need to find the the way how
you can cooperate your pieces together
how you can create the idea of
threatening the blacks King using these
pieces also Bishop on a4 you will need
to open the file so this is the main
hint I will give you the hint so the
first move is before we are trying to
open up the space open C file
is it easy no once night Acheson before
the geometry of the Queen and of the
King on the same diagonal and Challenger
of the rooks on the same file and the
bishop on the way do you see the 90s and
before
well just you move what can you offer
here in this position after Knight takes
and before
96 that's a good assumption night before
96 Chuck why couldn't we make this check
what helps us look at the geometry again
so the Queen on a for the King Khan ei
there you can see one there you can see
it we want to get rid of the Bishop on
c5 so if the bishop takes on d6 John
what will be the next move Bishop 66
rook takes a it correct so instead of
this move black plays King to e7
of course King can move to f8 first let
us calculate King Mo's to e7 Geraldton
why to play
the Lucas hankerin seed
just take the rook don't hesitate we
want to get that exchange that it that
is why we sacrifice the opponent before
to get exchanged if the King moves to f8
what are we going to do is it good like
with John short short combination in two
moves
go ahead the black smoke
and night takes 8 very good so returning
back to before the other move that we
are going to calculate is Bishop X
before the situation is a lot different
because if you play Knight to d6 check
we have one more piece on the way and on
the C file on the way of the rook so if
you play 96 check Bishop and d6 and we
do not get anything from sacrificing
that many pieces but instead here is
another hint that you have Jonathan
what's your move Knight to c7 what route
takes c6 I think that both lines work
here so let's go with 97 take bishop
takes
if queen takes you take with the rook
what are the next move rook c8 let's see
maybe black has some defense if you play
ninety-seven I don't really see anything
strong here do you guys see besides rook
xe7 what else
if King steps away then the knight and
c6 is hanging right so the only move is
root x e7 then Bishop X is 7 then again
if black doesn't take on c7 then just
the night is handled or he will return
back with a bishop right so the only
move and take so in the game this
position another solution was rook takes
c6 here and Queen before I think both
lives are possible here ok we are done
with this position and we are going back
well not going backward starting with
and games so as I promised today our
goal is to work on the end games this
position is called ready position have
you heard about Richard ready so he was
a very strong current master who was
born at the end of the 19th century and
lived the majority of his life in the
20th century so this is the end game and
the idea created by Richard rating what
is our goal here by the way why to play
you see the pawn on h5 the pawn is going
to become a queen really soon so blacks
King is in the square of the c6 pawn am
i right what about the white king is he
in the square of h5 phone no
however there is a possibility using the
read his idea how we can make the draw
with white maybe somebody has seen this
idea before so this will be refreshment
but I think it's really useful so white
to play find the idea how to make the
drop
so try to catch both phones so your idea
is to help your own phone and to catch
that foreign spawn and also another hint
if you cannot catch your opponent's
point it means that you're close to your
own point and you look at your point
your policy on c6 so if your King was
closer to the pawn it would be obvious
that the point is B is going to become a
queen so this means if you cannot catch
your opponent's pawn you can help your
own point to become a queen I will tell
the first move kingi salmon of course
not King h7 because the pawn will just
move to h5 from h5 to h4 excuse me and
just you will never stop it
what I think what will be the next month
John there are two variations right king
b6 and a an h4 so let's start with King
b6
Jimmy what is the next month what do you
think
how can we approach to the pond
very good that's right
king of six if I take on c6 mat what
will be the next wise move
if King from basics takes on c6
King to g5 very good if I move to h4 you
have to find another important move but
it's it's easy now again approaching to
c6 pawn and trying to get into the
square of H for pawn how can you do that
can you get five exactly if I play age
stream Jimmy
now if I play I mean here King a four
but I will play h2 and you already
cannot help your own one and then King
the 6h - Jonathan h1 Queen and we
promote C pawn so instead of King to b6
another move is age four
well basically we did not change
anything we just follow the same route
so we play King to f6 again if he plays
h3 we are playing King e6 e7 and help
the Khan to promote if our opponent
plays King to be six again let us repeat
the move matte white to play
no no no King g5 is looting because of
h3 everybody should be focused king came
to e5 exactly so keep t5 and you can
either approach today c6 pawn or catch
the each photon so once you got this
idea we are going to another and game
using the same idea you're going to to
make a drop is occurring this endgame
because from the first from the first
view what do you think what the result
what result is obvious here the black
wins but using Reddy's idea you're gonna
make draw so I give you I think three
four minutes to write down the line if
you are ready faster then just tell me
and I will check a solution the same
idea exactly but just in different
position but the same idea
I think everybody can guess the first
move right kingi six so after King G 6
you should write down the line for me
the next blacks move is clear - am i
right John Kim to b6 so starting with
this position
write me a couple of moves so you have
some time try to write all the
variations that you can find here you
guys have to write down the variation
after f5 so not kink takes c6 but f5 or
h5 they both are the same idea
so we are at the following position King
takes ff5 here this is what I want you
to write your your all road key takes c6
if King took on c6 then you would have
taken on f6 and the phone and h6
will will now promote to f5 this is what
you have to figure out what you're going
to do
so it's understandable that we need to
approach with the King to the pawns
right so king of six if King takes into
six John tell me the next one if King
takes into six King takes a five and
again the King isn't the square of the
point h6 if I move to f4 Jimmy what will
be your next move
Katie five right if I take on c6 Matt
King gap for right if I move to AB stray
King can you stop a stream now
impossible tell me what will be your
next move
you meant d6 right Q to d6 up to c7
Queen Queen of course black has the pawn
on each season but it will be really
really hard to promote this pawn and to
defend from the HX okay did you get the
idea of ready trying to catch the rabbit
right we're going to work on the rookin
game have you heard about such thing as
umbrella and the rookin games now when
your King is under attack under checks
in the rook endgames
what can we do other any possibilities
how we can escape so number one we can
approach to the rook and try to stop the
chucks
just imagine that the rook is giving the
checks on the open files and you cannot
block it at all so you have the
possibility to approach what else
this is exactly what we're going to
review so umbrella is when the kink is
hiding behind the opponent's pawn so can
you guess the next move
can you hide behind jittery behind this
phone no trailer right so let us go with
this relation first it would give the
check from beat you for example jamia
please with black and John plays with
white so John this is your move you go
here right and now if I want to approach
the King to come closer and go to f3
Jamia what will be an expo
be attentive
you have much much better move here
rook the rook takes a five right so this
move returning back so we understood
that this is the goal Ruby - and king of
stream this what will bring us success
by playing with black so in order to
create a kind of umbrella from the
checks what do we need to do here Matt
so the question is in f5 pawn this is a
very useful trick especially when you
pawn is already on eastery and you want
to get rid of those annoying checks that
will not let you promote your pawn to
the Queen
f4 you use your own phone to trade it
for the opponent's pawn you know that
when we have extra material and they in
the rook and games we have to be careful
with trading because first of all rook
and games is considered to be the most
complicated part of the end games there
are so many different variations and you
have to know the main philidor's
positions how to win and to which
position you're going to get so they're
really complex and even strong
grandmasters they review and games from
time to time to refresh so go ahead
charlatan repeater
if I move here
King extreme what you go checkmate
or if I try to escape
what they're going to do easy you're
going to promote but how just maybe like
this and if you move to G tune this is
let us see him I think if I move to f1
then you will promote for sure right can
get one then met what will be the
variation if King moves to f1 but I
would met to say that II to King you
want and rook to g1 right and then you
promote in the pond but instead I will
move here so I will complicate your life
you came here
okay I see a goal you want to play king
of - right okay probable let me see
maybe I can stop you here so if the king
up - no way
so returning back if I blame some other
mouth if I give it a check for example
you have to and I'm up here
here mm-hmm
and I have no defense again do you have
any chance here if you play this line to
stop you
I think it also brings success but plain
Ruby one check Kinkos this is just
easier just you're promoting quickly
okay
instead of kingi one what if I play a
rook a1 how are you going to play here
you will need the rook on the second
rank
so Jonathan your ideas will happen here
after rook e1 John what is your next
move
to Institute
exactly
I have the only move King to g1 go ahead
how we're going to win
what is what is a plus of this app for
fun that the rook cannot go to the
eighth-ranked and check from the
backside right otherwise it will be
really if we do not have the pawn on f4
that will be really hard to defend from
the checks from the back rank so what is
our next move
let's continue
well look don't you - but what is your
idea of the root 2 G to your chicken if
kink moves to F F 1 then you're winning
with already familiar idea eat - and
then root G 1 right so I have the only
move to H 1
let us see so basically it's like the
idea is closer to what we had before but
I have one extra temper here what if I
move here rotate okay I think it's again
it's unstoppable I don't see any defense
do you guys have any other ideas
besides rookie one so if we give Chuck
then King moves here and there is no
chance for giving up the rook like this
because we have the pawn on f5 so this
doesn't work
so the rook is redundant work are there
I think he too works too Ruby it was in
the game room Jade and I I think here
it's it's easily a winner right look
Jonathan your variation before so it too
and it's really hard to do something
against you one so what did we learn
from this endgame
let us repeat what did we learn how can
we protect against those annoying checks
when we have this passing point on the
third ring Jonathan
the umbrella right how do we create the
umbrella
you said the material or basically this
is we sacrifice for some time we can all
the time we can return a pawn back that
we sacrifice it and we block be filed
from the checks okay good job now we are
going to last course idea have you have
you made this and game before no okay
so Oscar created this idea in order to
help like in this position to help white
to win the game so you see that from
first opinion it's close to draw and if
black to pull it was to play here most
likely the troll will happen so the kink
will move to a seven and then wise King
cloves to d8 then you give the check
from d2 and then return back to C to
control in this line or bring the King
to b7
but why to play so I will give it a hint
and now the name of this is elevator
what did the first move what do you
think I showed you very good hint
so if black was to play here then he
would have played King to a seven
controlling b8 and b7 so the first move
that we're going to make if you play
rook to h6 you just help me
thanks a lot King g7 of course we do not
want King j7 what are the first move
Jimmy if we do not want ki to a7 how we
can prevent it the King to be king to be
eight right so after you move the King
to b8
now what is your threat mad
c8 is your strength you're going to
promote the only opportunity how I can
defend is to give you check back right I
go in back to c8 we are going to any aid
of course and again you Stratton what CH
queen to promote so I'm forced to return
back to city keep in mind elevator so
you're going up up up
Jonathan real good six Jimmy
Matt
black to plane what do you think what
will be the next move the only more room
wrong [ __ ] Oh kinky seven right I
returned back to CTO John Luke to h5
check King here
Jamia no king b7 because if you move the
King to b6 you're not you do not have
any threat
you're not going to promote the ponte c8
you're just protecting the pawn but
after moving to b7 again you shred and
seeing it Queen gentle elevator king if
you play king c6 again you're helping me
rooks you to check try to use the king
the opponent's king is an umbrella like
in the previous example you use the pawn
don't forget about h2 phone you cannot
create the bridge here where is thinking
about the bridge King c6 and rook c5
yeah so the pollen h2 also wants to
become a queen don't forget about that
King is this right I returned back to
see tune so met your next move elevator
we go up
Jonah
pink to basics and here what is your
thread
Jonathan take on each to give you chat
back Mad King where King to 85 I have to
return back Jimmy
look at SRI chucks kink goes here
chan
and finally we got to the position where
rook takes h2 that was our goal
how did you like it was it good the
elevator well you will you'll have to
work on that we can we can play that if
you want that's a good idea
so take know this you can try to make
the draw but it's really really hard
really hard ok let's play that was a
good idea what let's play ok thank you
very much for the attention today I hope
we had much fun and you learned new
ideas we'll learn great ideas we learned
last clear ideas we weren't up with good
puzzles we worked a little bit on the
Queen against the rook end game so now
you will have some work to do at home